Twitter is coming out of the shadows
remember all these media figures
accusing the social platform of sneakily
hiding their posts from their followers
feeds what Big Brother hides from us
what is referred to as shadow banning
may be even more pernicious if you're on
the left
maybe you're okay with this but if
you're not on the left or even if you
are and you Revere the First Amendment
you should be concerned that's actually
been while substantiate advice news
which is not a right-wing outlet says
that this is happening on a routine
basis to a lot of folks on the right
side of the aisle but almost never to
people on the left side of the aisle do
not free speech that's where it's saying
is that you got to be balanced House
Leader Kevin McCarthy wrote our Chairman
a letter and said hey this is going on
and we think your committee should
investigate it and how the Twitter boss
made a surprise and innocent face saying
that oh no no no there are definitely
not going behind anyone's backs to
quietly hide their opinions Twitter
undertook no behavior to selectively
censor conservative Republicans or
conservative voices on your platform
that correct correct well apparently all
those assurances were just a big pile of
nonsense now for those of you know too
tech-savvy
I'm talking about a thing called shadow
banning - the shadow banned user
everything looks just fine they can log
into their account follow comment like
even post tweets but crucially their
posts are simply not shown in other
people's feeds even if they are
subscribed to the user Twitter had been
adamantly denying that it does this
until it slipped this one small change
into their constitution we may also
remove or refuse to distribute any
content on the services limit
distribution or visibility of any
content on the service suspend or
terminate users and reclaim usernames
without liability to you it's a case
where just a couple of words make all
the difference the part about limiting
tweet with
ability was not in the previous edition
of the document here it is nothing of
the sort there and one can only wonder
why Twitter has decided to come clean
all of a sudden
perhaps because after all the outcry
from the users wronged by the platform
that simply made no sense in denying it
anymore or and maybe because a Twitter
staffer had previously outright
confessed to shadow banning already on
hidden camera you banned someone but
they don't know they've been bad because
they keep posting but no one sees their
content there's even a lawsuit against
Twitter accusing it of discriminating
against conservative voices by employing
its shadow banning tactic but now that
it's in the Terms of Service some users
will just have to accept that they are
talking to themselves
you